я згоден пучок кінця тортур за виклик
нирки теж закривай свої котовські номери
і і наклеїв і українські наклейки так
он у жеки
бумерангом поверх на що ти готовий заради
свого боку піти воювати готовий та
можна попросити залишити своє прізвище та
підпис від патріотичний список та в
у випадку загальної мобілізації тебе в числі
перше чого чому ми краще мені так ти
сказав ти готовий, а що заважає нинішньому ж
не хочу не готовий немає на що готовий заради
країни померти немає він поки що я не готовий
ще чому страшно весь світ буде
дружити у нас росією, бо рубль
стане золотим золотим тло підкріплено
це папірці сьогодні ось ці доларові
які треба просто розірвати зустрічі
забути за не за п'ять хвилин доларів
життя не бачив долар ні в кого не
долара покажи дідово
який красивий але до капелюха з ними я теж
золотого після криму треба було б забрати її
якби мені доручили я давно забрав було
питанням тому при все-таки
стоїть салам алейкум вставай [ __ ] на
роботу пора ти че ебанутий спиш живемо
на роботу
не ходять
влади
[музика]
москаль бійся якраз я не їздять у
Європі видобувати уран з України
діткам ялинки карлик знав завантажуємо
ядерним ударом
bitter pill сотню але це перший молот по
виду наша тема 5 став розуміти що
радянська ядерна боєголовка тр-2 пуск
значить і ракет і вже не зупинитися
я проти тиму вигляду 2 став the curve вода
піде
[музика]
стефані мама
не носити
[музика]
Ігнатівна
своїх-то
і
[музика]
натерли
шампанське
чудово перевіряємо тут транспорт
все готове я не знаю хтось із наших з
наших зруби в ну реально васик право
мазь заводи був сильним місцям нуца
просто 36 ось купа їжі швидко як щоб
бруса залитий в Україну в них і наказ
паршута руб у лева то на блокпост з
білими ведмедиками у бару дружина була
постійно мішками он і думати штам
бульба
акуратно ніби
голову будь-кому українські військові
[музика]
друзі хакерська атака на мотив
хакерська атака на тобі говорити тому
сані арки
простого
ігри тварюки
обожнюю вас спс футбол на потрібен такий собі за
ваших днів
[оплески]
[музика]
макс
ці великі браво palestine було скинуто
взагалі бориса можу іншого предмета top
baby
[оплески]
і
число ,
я розкрив лора
сирожки
а там по
краще ти лети на дати і на
ну щож друзі у мене для вас дуже
гарний новий nan no rest in арешт ми
від рибу ловити не м'яч кульбабі на
допомогу грунт треба в нас при було
потрібно секретно збруя та
Дена проблема в тому що я kitty lps немає
ще москва а там потім москва вертай на
москву туди а
так прямо там же стоїть доба за нами
[музика]
яхта служба бути перуки для вас дач
ракета гепнуло не заходить значить було to
take 2 варіння залі задуманої дух арти та
зачала краси все що потрапило scar п'яти
труси а в них же дрібничок провулка на
роботі зроблю хлопче то все грязно а ви
зате фірмова зрушив і
забрав і але все взяти і скорботу та тканинах
було поховано 3 тисячі євро головні на
відео нанівець ногу б сказала щоб перший
якщо таке бачать і це напевно щось
сувенірні зуб інші плани путіна та каша
у неї хвороба зруби ешу стравами вигадав
і російські і непродумані видно і і кейсі
вікі-віки в кути на трапезу планети в
Першим і амінь досі не руси і тут і
фігуристки згущеним молоком і чупа-чупси
[музика]
друзі
все нормально
не плачу буде добре обов'язково путін
допоможе він усім допомагає і американці
Росії з'явись інтерактивної карти
смітник це така підказка нужденним
де точно бувають якісь продукти
користувачів новини русака що довго
шукати не довелося
і
опер з цією надав вам на готовий
опинилися прямо в голову через
центральне бачимо я живу тут уже багато
я українець
ми з сусідом, що ви
хоче
[музика]
доказів і думала червового генерала арки
генерал-лейтенанта кутузова пом'ятою
тицялися кутузів спав і в москву так ось
за силу на стику крута шутер спав і лу
і москву крейсера і кутузова за чоловіка
баскову
[музика]
український
ведений номер я кажу алла там здається
слава україні героям слава як слава
нації як смерть
теж україна говорю понад усе путін
з pivot та бочку наш бандера
моя перехід чи україна мати і
не пам'ятаю поле сили тугіше буковини додому
землі
зайнятися
знизуємо рядки ляже на піку
виходить це куди гул входить пластик вам
стрілок москаль бійся гулу збр вони хочуть
йти куди гонку від злості пункти мій
мозок арт бійся